today on the matt wells show it wasn't a
noose it turns out as any intelligent
person already knew but still the left
the media bubba wallace himself
are trying to retain the narrative even
as it's exposed as fraudulent
uh they don't care they're gonna keep it
going so we're gonna sort through all
this today and i wanna
pay special attention to the fact that
the fbi
sent 15 federal agents to investigate a
rope in a garage
so we're going to talk about that also
five headlines including protesters
quote unquote protesters tearing down a
statue
of an abolitionist why why are they
doing that well i'll explain the real
reason why all these statues are coming
down plus the daily cancellation and
much more
all that coming up coming up on the show
today but we begin
with uh rock otto our sponsor of the
show today one of our good friends over
at rockauto
uh you know and it's it's it's really
a lot easier i think going online than
having to go to a store just in general
but especially when it comes to auto
parts um you know because there
are so many different options what you
could possibly need that if you go into
a store they're gonna be very limited
they're probably gonna end up
just buying the stuff online anyway
that's why cut that cut out that whole
process
no need for any of that nonsense go to
rockauto.com always offering the lowest
prices
the best selection everything that you
need they're not going to change the
prices to try to
gouge you or get as much as they can out
of you they're going to give you the
lowest prices they possibly can
rockauto.com is a family business honest
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years you go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
whatever you need
um i'm telling you they've got it there
the rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate and you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your car
truck and make your decision make your
choice buy what you need and get on with
your day go to rockauto.com right now
it's rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck and make sure to write walsh in
their how did you hear about us box so
they know that uh
that i sent you okay shocker of shockers
who besides me and anyone else with a
brain could have possibly seen
seeing this coming who besides besides
those of us with iqs above that of a of
a soggy paper towel
could have ever predicted this outcome
the noose in bubba wallace's garage was
not a hate crime
uh it was just a rope a rope to pull the
door closed
that's it now before we get into this
let's let's reminisce just for a moment
reminisce uh about the old days back in
the good old days back way way back two
days ago in fact
when nascar came out in an emotional
show of support for bubba wallace and
the other drivers
escorted him around the track as he wept
openly
before talladega and then nascar put
together this inspirational video let's
just remember this video again
watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all of that over a garage door
all of that because bubba wallace was
afraid of his garage door
we are truly living in an idiocracy i
it now here's the statement from nascar
um in this
this remember after they spent the
previous day condemning this racist
vile act and rallying around bubba and
putting together inspirational
videos with the with the inspirational
music in the background and then they
come out with this and they say the fbi
has completed its investigation at
talladega super speedway determined that
bubba wallace was not the target of a
hate crime
the fbi report concludes and
photographic evidence confirms that the
garage door pull rope fashioned like a
noose has been
positioned there since as early as last
fall this was obviously well before the
43 teams arrived
and um and we're given their garage
assignments
we appreciate the fbi's quick and
thorough investigation are thankful to
learn that this was not an intentional
racist act against bubba we remain
steadfast in our commitment to providing
a welcoming and inclusive environment
for all who love racing but the left and
the media
nascar bubba wallace all of them they're
not they're not ready to let this go
they're not gonna they're gonna let this
go so easily okay
and they certainly won't admit that they
were wrong that's not gonna happen and
even more certainly
they're not gonna apologize they will
not apologize to those of us who were
skeptical of the story
and were right and were accused of
racism because of our skepticism
no one's coming back around no i was i
was i was called a racist
many times over the last few days well
i'm always called that just like every
other istanism i'm called
but especially the last few days because
i was immediately skeptical of this
story
and i was told that's because you're a
racist i i'm i'm here i'm available if
you want to come and apologize
uh you want to send me a letter send me
an email i am ready to accept your acts
of contrition
if there are any takers surprisingly
there aren't
wallace said earlier yesterday that
skeptics were simple-minded
he insulted us called us stupid
do you think he's apologizing for saying
that is he going to at least apologize
for that is he at least going to say
hey you know maybe it turns out you
weren't very simple-minded i mean
it it it turns out you're actually on to
something
in fact you guys uh who were not even
there
and didn't have all the information that
i had
you were able to figure this out in 10
seconds
so wow not only are you not
simple-minded but compared to me you're
a genius
you guys are like you should be private
private eyes your detectives
you were on the case no he's not going
to say that
he just called us idiots and he's going
to leave it at that and he's still
making himself into the victim
wallace went on cnn last night for well
i'm not going to call it an interview it
certainly was not an interview
it was more of a therapy session don
lemon the alleged news anchor
didn't ask any prying questions or
really any questions at all didn't try
to get to the truth
never does of course instead he just he
just complimented and soothed
bubba and told him how wonderful he is
in fact
i you know i watched this for some
reason i subjected myself to it because
i'm a masochist i suppose
but really don lemon did most of the
talking
and he spent the whole time just telling
bubba
nobody blames you this isn't your fault
you're a great guy
you know we all understand where you're
coming from
if if the media was capable of
embarrassment they would be
embarrassed by that sickening spectacle
um and bubba agreed by the way of course
bubba agreed that he's a wonderful
guy and brave and he said so many times
in so many words
i kept talking about how i'm i'm still
standing up i'm not gonna let this stop
me
it's a garage door opener what do you
mean you're still
standing up and you're brave i'm not
gonna be
they're not gonna stop me no garage door
is gonna stand in my way
um but here he is at the very beginning
because he's still making himself a
victim here he is at the very beginning
beginning of this foe interview saying
that uh he's still the victim you know
he's not the victim of a hate crime but
because there wasn't one but now he's
the victim of people who doubted the
hate crime
even though the doubters were right he's
still the victim of them
watch this i'm uh i'm pissed
i'm i'm mad because people are trying to
test
my character and the person that i am
and my integrity
and they're not stealing that away from
me but they're just trying to test that
and uh as a person don that
doesn't need the fame doesn't need to
hype doesn't need the media i could care
less i could give
two craps about that um but to sit there
and then read and that's my problem i'm
reading too much into it and
i'm investing too much time into it i am
i don't
don't don't don't i know i know i know
i i'm trying hard not to and after
tonight i'll probably turn my phone off
uh unfortunately until about 7 30 in the
morning where the interviews start back
up again and we get it all over
and then and then so we have that uh
he's still a victim
later on he insists that it was a noose
he doubles down and claims that you know
he's it was still a noose and he's never
in his life
never in his life has he seen a rope
with a loop on it
hanging in a garage watch
i've uh i've been racing all my life
i've we've raced out of
hundreds of garages that uh never had
garage pools like that so
people that want to call it garage pool
and put out old videos and photos of of
knots
being um in in in their as their
evidence go ahead but
from the evidence that we have um
that i have uh it's a straight up news
the fbi has stated it was a news over
and over again nascar
leadership has stated that it was a
noose i can confirm that i
actually got evidence of what was
hanging in my garage
over my car around my picker guys to
confirm that it was a noose
and never seen anything like it
never seen it never ever couldn't
couldn't possibly imagine
ever seeing something like that um and
but the left also as i said is not ready
to let this go
here's al sharpton calling for further
investigations
into the potentially racist garage door
we should take it as good news that
someone didn't place it into his stall
specifically as the only full-time black
driver in nascar
who pushed to have those confederate
flags removed from nascar events and
nascar did take that step
last week but it does appear there was a
noose as the fbi is calling it
placed in that garage last fall the fbi
identified it as a noose
nascar said it was a new or went along
with the fbi's characterization
it was a noose so the question is even
if they did not know that
bubba wallace was going to use that
stall
why was a noose in the stall it's clear
what a noose represents
and i think to to go whether or not they
knew that sooner or later the one black
driver would use that stall
really doesn't answer why it was in the
stall
at all and then did someone know
that it was in the stall when they did
belatedly
assigned bubba there so i don't think
this answers a lot of questions and
clearly from what we just saw
of bubba wallace it does not seem he who
is the victim and possible target in
this matter
seems to be satisfied with this i do not
think that we've seen closure in this
particular
or inquiry okay there's a bunch of other
stuff like that from the left in the
media uh you know oh it still might be a
hate crime
why was there a noose there in the first
place even if it wasn't a hate crime it
still could have been
so we had a valuable conversation that
we needed to have we should thank bubba
for that
bub was innocent in this he didn't know
you know that it wasn't a hate crime it
was reasonable for him to interpret it
the way that he did
and the excuses go on and on and on so i
want to make a few points about this
we're going to go through this one by
one as we sort through it
um and as we continue to dissect and
analyze a piece of rope in a garage
because this is this is what we do now
and it's a it's a worth
it's a it's a good way to spend our time
so number one
it was not a news okay um
that's that's not what it is a news
is a certain type of knot and the whole
point of it is that if you put weight on
it
it tightens that's why it's also called
a hangman's knot
and yes they use it to hang people they
also use it for many non-lethal
applications so a noose and that's the
other part of this that's sort of a
side note but this idea that a
a new you know quote unquote noose is a
some sort of universal
sign of of racism since when did that
become the case
these these types of knots slip knots
are
very useful people use them for
practical reasons all the time
when i see a knot like that i don't
immediately think oh someone's gonna die
that's not what i think
um but this was uh this was more of just
a standard loop knot it was not a slip
knot
and we know that because you aren't
gonna make a slip knot to close a garage
door
the night the knot would tighten around
your your hand you're not going to make
a
a noose to close the garage door
you put weight on it think about you get
a heavy garage door to nas
nascar garage and you grab a noose
around your hand and you yank down
that's a good way to break your hand
that's not if the thing was hanging
there for a year
then it was not a noose no way was it a
noose
people do not make nooses to close
garages with they don't use them as
handles
part of the problem here maybe an
underrated aspect of this story
is that the left is comprised of a bunch
of
wusses you know a bunch of a bunch of
wusses and shut-ins who have no
practical knowledge at all
and never go outside they don't know how
to identify
basic knots when they see them
you know sharpton says why was it in the
garage at all well
that's not a mystery it was it was there
to hold on to as you close the door
yes in many garages the pull down will
have a handle or a little lever or
something to grab
but you see al sometimes men
rather than sometimes they'll just tie a
knot or do something like that to solve
a problem rather than going out to
lowe's and buying a specific garage door
closer
they might say hey let me just tie a
knot that's what a man's going to do
this is what men do we tie knots we also
use duct tape
okay so many times we say i don't need i
i fixed a hole in my kayak the other day
with duct tape okay
good as new at least for now until i
drown in the lake
uh this is what we do we tie knots we
use duct tape
i mean you don't know much about that
apparently about just being a normal guy
i think you know people need just like
go do some camping
do some fishing learn about basic knots
no i'm not a i'm not a not expert myself
by the way mostly because most of the
not tying i do is fishing
and the palomar knot is really gonna
it's basically
indestructible it's almost the only knot
you need a couple other knots uh like
the arbor knot which is when you tie the
line around the reel but the palomar
knot when it comes to tying a hook i've
you know i've been using that i haven't
had a broken i haven't lost a
a a fish to a broken knot in years i've
lost its broken line you know or because
the fish jumps up because you don't keep
the
rod tip down when you're reeling it in
but um anyway
what were we talking about oh yeah um
bubba wallace okay
so that's that that's that number two
an attempt is being made to absolve
bubba wallace
of all guilt in this case and
we're being told that this is not a
jesse smallett situation uh
it's it's really not similar at all it's
a completely different type of thing
and besides wallace isn't the one who
called the feds he didn't report it he
didn't see it that's what we're told
well let me say if you fell for the
original story
and now you're falling for the story
that bubba didn't know
and was innocent then congratulations
you got fooled by the hoax
and are now being fooled by the hoax
that covers the other hoax you got
fooled by
you damned [ __ ] listen
let let me explain this do you know how
i i knew this is
this is this was probably not a hate
crime anyone anyone who knew it how did
we know
that it wasn't do you know what what
magical sorcery we used to see the
future and predict this outcome
well i'll tell you okay here's the
sorcery it's called common sense
that's all it takes common sense common
sense told us that there probably wasn't
a hate crime news
hanging in a nascar garage with security
and cameras
and stuff like that all around we just
we knew it immediately
that's probably not the case there's
probably another explanation
common sense also tells us and you
should listen to our common sense
because
you know you apparently have none so you
can borrow ours for a minute
common sense also tells us that even if
the initial person who saw the quote
unquote noose really did misinterpret it
which is i possible maybe they did
it would not have taken very long for
everyone else down the line to figure
out the truth
so when someone comes to you and tells
you there's a noose in your garage and
it's a hate crime
your next immediate response is not
going to be wow okay let's alert the
press
no no that's see that's again just
comment says yes i was not there
i can't prove this but common sense
tells me that is not how human
interactions work
no your response is going to be
something like what are you serious let
me see let me let me go see it for
myself
and then you go and you look or you look
at a photo and you would
then see that it's a rope hanging from a
garage
and you would at a minimum realize that
it's at least
possible that this is a totally innocent
thing
so again the only innocently duped
person
was maybe possibly the first person who
saw the thing
everyone else from wallace to nascar
president everyone else
they at a minimum would have known that
there's a good chance
it's not a hate crime they would have
known that because they would have
looked at it
and seen that it's a loop knot hanging
from a garage door opener
[Music]
and assuming that these are not actual
certifiable clinical lunatics we're
dealing with
they at least somewhere in their in
their head
in a probably pretty prominent place
would have been the thought of
you know this could really just be
nothing
and yet they all came out
wallace included stated as
fact that it's a hate crime an act of
hate despicable was the word that
wallace used
in a very self-ingrandizing way talking
about how he's he's going to stand up
he's not going to be intimidated
i will not be i will not be intimidated
i will not be cowed down under the under
the
weight of this garage door no
see that's that's what he did he didn't
say
hmm you know guys this is a little bit
concerning but let's check it out and
see what's going on uh
it might be fine that would have been a
good response
that would have been a response that an
innocent and and
intelligent and honest person would have
given an even better response would have
been hey guys calm down like it's it's
just it's a garage door opener i'm sure
that's all this is okay
he chew he chose neither of those
responses instead he went
all in on the hate crime despite at
least
knowing that there's a likely innocent
explanation so
did he perpetrate a hoax yes absolutely
100
100 this is a hoax and and yes he was
he was the ring one of the ringleaders
of it
um maybe not one that he planned or
staged
maybe not one that he paid two nigerian
dudes to carry out but it's a hoax all
the same
also keep in mind that wallace went on
the view
after he'd been interviewed by the fbi
he said in the interview that he you
know that he
talked to the fbi the fbi at that point
would have already looked at the tapes
and known that it wasn't a hate card
they would have figured that out in 15
seconds
as soon as they now if they've got any
common sense at all they would have
known it as soon as they looked at the
rope
but but if if not then
then as soon as they looked at the
security camera footage and saw that
okay that thing's been there for months
over a year they would have known so by
the time they talked to wallace
they knew that this was not a hate crime
and that fact would have come up in the
quote interview in fact i doubt that it
was really an interview at all
it was more of a meeting of the fbi
saying hey listen this wasn't a hate
crime
i would say 90 certainty that that's
what the interview was
because there'd be nothing for them to
interview wallace about at that point
um yet he still went on on the view and
perpetuated the
hate crime hoax and
even shamed and insulted
the people who he knew were right that
it wasn't a hate crime so this guy this
guy is a liar
and a fraud the fact that
how how gullible and stupid do you have
to be
that you fell for it the first time
falling for it again
good god i really think there are a lot
of people in this country that just love
being fooled
they they they love making asses of
themselves they enjoy it
number three here's the most important
thing to focus on i want to read the fbi
statement to you
because there's one thing in this
statement that really jumps out
let me pull it up okay fbi statement
says on monday 15 fbi special agents
conducted numerous interviews regarding
the situation at talladega
super speedway after a thorough review
of the facts and evidence surrounding
the event we have concluded that no
federal hate crime
was committed um and then it goes on
from there
i don't even need to go any further what
i'm really
homing in on here is 15
fbi agents
investigated a rope in a garage
15 fbi and they're proud of it
they're telling us we were on the case
15 15 sp what are these what are they
doing
i i know what one guy's gonna one guy
looks at the rope
and probably at that point says hey guys
it's just a it's just a loop now just
you close the garage with it look see
here look that's all you do
so one guy is doing that maybe another
guy goes and then and then and then
another guy is told hey go check the
security camera let's be sure about this
okay that's two guys at most what are
the other 13 guys doing
what are they what exactly are they
doing are they dusting for fingerprints
are they was they doing
doing a forensic investigation
good lord now
what makes this even more uh it goes
from being absurd and almost funny
to actually infuriating when you realize
that the federal government sent 15
agents to look at a
freaking rope in a garage
while there are violent mobs
tearing our cities apart as we speak
tearing down monuments and statues
statues
burning buildings that's still going on
attacking police officers
and there's a lot that the federal
government could and should be doing
about
this there are a lot of questions
that they could be investigating there
are a lot of arrests they could be
making and
and things they could be investigating
like what are the groups
backing these these violent
quote-unquote protesters
you know who's funding blm who's funding
antifa
they could be investigating that kind of
stuff
you put 15 special agents on that put
put put 50 put 100.
the full force of the federal government
and our in the federal government's law
enforcement arm
should be focused on this that we have
violent insurrectionists
right now trying to tear the country
apart
and they're all over the place and you
send 15 agents
for a rope
my god uh and
and that is the headline that's the real
headline of all this
is the federal government's involvement
even if i mean
even if it was a news okay even if even
if some
jerk had put a noose there as a hate
crime
even then what the hell do you need 15
agents for
why do you need any federal agents for
that
if you're going to involve law
enforcement all in a situation like that
then you know
i'm sure a local cop could could handle
it a local cop can go and look at the
security camera and see who did it
and find that guy so
even if this was a verified hate crime
it would still be
insane to send 15 federal agents for it
but it's not
all right let's move on to headlines
number one
lincoln county in oregon has issued a
new order requiring that everyone wear
masks in public
but the order exempts quote people of
color
so if you're a black person you don't
have to wear mask if you're white you do
the reason given is that black people
might be concerned about racial
profiling here's the the
reading out from the daily wire says the
post sites aclu racial justice program
director
renika moore who said uh who told cnn
for many black people deciding whether
or not to wear a bandana in public to
protect themselves and others from
contracting coronavirus is a lose-lose
situation
that can result in life-threatening
consequences either way
cnn quoted trevin logan who is black
also
as saying a mandate to wear face
coverings are basically telling black
people
to look dangerous given racial
stereotypes that are out there
this is in the large context of black
men fitting the description of a suspect
who has a hood on
who has a face covering on okay so
first of all has there have there been
any cases of
a black person who's wearing a face
covering for coronavirus
you know getting assaulted or shot or
arrested
erroneously has that happened at all is
there one case of it
one single case but the aclu is is
certain that this is a big problem
they're certain it's a big problem
okay it's a pr is it if it's a problem
that it should be happening
is it happening if it's not happening
then it's not a problem there's some
more basic common sense for you
if a thing is not happening then it's
not a problem because it's not happening
but the other issue here is that there's
no way this is constitutional
there is no way that a law specifically
exempting a certain race
is constitutional which isn't to say
that it will be
that it's going to be struck down by by
the courts i'm i'm not predicting that
at all
just because the law is unconstitutional
doesn't mean the the court's going to
strike it down
and just because uh uh you know just
because the law is constitutional
doesn't mean that the court won't strike
at that we know that how it works the
court's full of far-left activists as we
know but in reality
the constitution does not allow this
this is not equality under the law
you can't make an ordinance and say if
you're if you have a certain skin
pigmentation you don't have to follow it
number two and uh in statute toppling
news protesters quote unquote in
wisconsin
tore down the lady forward statue here's
a picture of that and then they defaced
and tore down the hans christian hague
monument in wisconsin this was all in
one night
lady forward is a monument to social
progress
haig was an abolitionist and a union
soldier
who i believe died in the civil war
pretty sure about that
uh this was someone who just dedicated
his whole life to abolishing slavery
that was his he was a
anti-slavery activist and put his money
where his mouth is on it
so and yet they tore his statue down
and they tore down a statue to progress
[Music]
which i i think is is very appropriate
in fact because yes these are enemies of
progress
but you wouldn't think that they would
see themselves that way
so why did these statues have to come
down
why well because the statues depicted
white people
that's it that that's really all there
is to it now
if it's a statue of a white person it
has to come down
that's the only litmus test this is this
is racism
and if it was a crowd if it was a white
crowd
let's say a crowd of of violent uh
white supremacists who were tearing down
statues of black people for no
discernible reason
other than their race we'd call it a
hate crime
on top of not only would they be
arrested for destruction or property
property
they would also be arrested for
committing a hate crime
yet in this case you've got violent
left-wing mobs going around tearing down
statues
for note i mean the reason doesn't even
matter i don't care what your reason is
but it's worth noting that at this point
their only reason
is that's a statue of a white person
that can be the only that could
be the only coherent uh vaguely coherent
reason to tear down a statue of an
abolitionist or a statute of progress
is that it's depicting a white person so
this is a racist campaign to take down
monuments to white americans
which isn't to say that these are
monuments to white america
they are no these are monuments to
individual americans who happen to be
white and also happen to do incredible
and great things
but they have to come down so this is
racism
the only other thing it could be and i
think also is it's kind of a combination
of these things
is destruction for destruction's sake
nihilism
sociopathy all of this is mixed into it
i think there are people involved who
just want to tear down a statue because
it's fun there's a lot of that
there are people involved who just don't
care about anything um
sociopaths nihilists there are people
involved who have a
beef with western civilization in
general and then there are people
involved who just want to tear down
statues of white people
all of that is mixed in so nihilism
sociopathy
uh psychopathy racism
all of that bigotry yeah number three
here's somebody at a trump event talking
about the american dream
aunt jemima was cancelled
and and if you didn't know nancy greene
the original first aunt jemima she was a
picture of the american dream
she was a freed slave who went on to
be the face of the pancake syrup that we
love and
have in our pantries today the american
dream is to be
the face of pancake syrup that
that could be someone's dream people are
making fun of this uh
this girl for for saying that but i you
know could be someone's
personally i'd like to be the face of
dijon mustard i know so much
you know syrup not really not really my
thing but uh if i was in the face of any
kind of condiment i'd love to be the
face of
dijon mustard that's that's my great
dream and goal uh
in life it's the only thing i want to
achieve
but we all have our own dreams of course
number four as if we didn't have enough
problems on our hands already uh now a
massive cloud of dust
is floating our way from the sahara
desert cbs news reports
a massive plume of dust from the sahara
desert in north africa
has been traversing the atmosphere
thousands of feet above the tropical
atlantic
atlantic ocean and is now cloaking the
caribbean and closing in on the
southeastern u.s
um while summer dust plumes
are common currents this appears to be
one of the most extreme in recent memory
pablo mendes lazora from the university
of puerto rico's
school of public health said this is the
most significant event in the past 50
years conditions are dangerous in many
caribbean islands
wait a second what the most significant
event in 50 years
the dust the dust is the most
significant event of 50 years
maybe he means this is the most
significant dust-related event
uh and and that i could see though
personally i think the great dust storm
of 87 or maybe the dust cloud of 72
could perhaps rival this but this is a
debate that never ends among dust
enthusiasts
um the dust enthusiast community so
that's
that's interesting anyway but look out
for the dust on on
on its way over here five finally sports
writer
genius and scholar rob parker has
written an article for deadspin
that i'm pretty sure is not a parody you
can never be entirely sure these days
but uh here's here's here's the article
he says that the name of the masters
must now be changed and here's how he
argues the point he says
the name the masters must go the
heralded the heralded
golf tournament one of the four majors
needs to go back to its original name
the augusta national invitation
it became the masters in 1939. tiger
woods
other big time golfers and corporate
sponsorships should demand it in the
current climate with all the sweeping
changes it's only right and just
best of all in this case it's a simple
and smooth fix
the masters never felt good or even
sounded good when you said it
and before we hear from the choir about
tradition and history save it
when that history and tradition is
rooted in slavery it shouldn't be
preserved and honored
augusta national was built on grounds
that were once a slave plantation and
was the property
of a slave owner so then why do you want
to call the augusta national invitation
you're saying it you want to name it
after property that was that
was was owned by a slave owner i don't
understand how that's an improvement
and according to a 2019 new yorker piece
about the course it's believed that
enslaved blacks were housed on the
property
and be honest when you hear anyone say
the masters you think of slave masters
in the south
there's nothing else nothing special you
don't think of
someone mastering the game of golf what
has anyone
mastered when has anyone mastered golf
i i can't even i can't continue
i'm losing brain cells brain cells are
leaking out of my ear
as i as i speak right now i can feel
them dropping out
like dandruff just falling falling onto
my shoulders
this is when you hear the masters you
don't think of someone mastering the
game of golf
that's exactly what i think that's what
any normal person thinks
when have you heard of someone mastering
golf i don't know i mean everybody at
the masters has mastered it pretty much
they're professional golfers
yes be honest be honest when you hear of
the master's golf tournament your mind
immediately conjures images of slave
masters
golfing i admit it be honest
oh wait you don't think of that okay
that was just my own psychosis talking
okay then
no but rob really makes a good point i
think i i because i also think
uh the name of the show master chef
should be changed because when i hear
masterchef i think of
slave owners baking cakes
the rapper master p has to change his
name obviously
masterpiece theater can't have that
because that brings to mind a piece of a
slave master
just a piece of him like like an arm or
something lying there
a masterpiece so maybe that's okay
actually because that that brings to
mind
dismembered slave owners
maybe that's okay i don't know i don't
know what the new rules are
but there's rob parker with a great take
as always
we're gonna move on to our daily
cancellation
before we do we've been telling you
about this reader's pass if you're not
already a daily wire member you should
consider getting a reader's pass
to dailywire.com it's a great value only
three dollars a month
and when you sign up you get the first
month for only 99 cents you also get
access to our mobile app articles ad
free
access to exclusive editorials that
we're all writing uh
like uh you know a recent editorial i
wrote about the white privilege myth
which i would really recommend
uh getting a great reaction to that well
i don't know if i call it great reaction
great as in the the passion behind the
reaction and the amount
of reaction but much of it is not
positive but anyway you can want you can
read that and so many other great
editorials
if you haven't checked out the reader's
pass already go to dailywire.com sign up
for
just a buck now daily cancellation today
we're going to be canceling the claim
that america is a racist country
and in canceling it i'd like to echo the
point made by many others
that you know if america was truly a
racist country if racism
was rampant in our country as it is
claimed then there wouldn't be any need
or desire
you know to invent hate crimes the
existence of guys like jesse smilet
and bubba wallace and the prevalence of
these hoaxes
and the in fact the fact that the
intelligent among us knew
that the new story was a hoax just
because they are so often hoaxes
this all amounts to very strong
circumstantial evidence against the
systemic racism theory
this does not in itself by itself
disprove systemic racism i think there's
other things you can look at that
uh make that essentially disprove it
but it's very good circumstantial
evidence
because this is not what you would
expect
in someone tells you about a
systemically racist country a country
that is
beset by racism and you don't know
anything about this country or this
culture
the last thing you would expect is that
the you know the people who are
allegedly victims of this
of this rampant systemic racism you know
would be would be inventing instances of
it
so let's think about why this keeps
happening we all know that it does keep
happening but
why does keep happening why would
someone do something like this
why pretend that a hate crime has been
committed against you
this happens so often but we bet we
rarely stop to ask
why would someone do this what's the
point
or why would you allow yourself to be
deceived into thinking that it has
happened
why would a person be eager to interpret
it this way
well it's because victimization is power
in our culture victimization is
trendy victimization means attention
admiration money
sympathy clout political influence
but is that how it would be if america
was systemically racist
could a person expect to profit off of
claims of racist victimization in a
racist country
how so how could they how could you
profit
off of a claim like that benefit from it
benefit from it so much that you would
make it up or be eager to interpret an
innocent act as a hate crime
if the country is actually racist now
you notice something look back through
history
um look at all the examples
unfortunately many examples of oppressed
groups and various societies
around the world
and including including in the history
of this country
in the history of this country there
obviously have been systemically
oppressed groups
but what you don't find in these
examples you don't often find these
groups
inventing additional oppression why not
well because there's nothing to be
gained from it they're oppressed
how much more oppression how would more
oppression help their cause they're
already oppressed
also they wouldn't need to invent it
even if they wanted to
even if they thought that somehow you
know an instance of oppression would
benefit them
they wouldn't need to invent it and
anyone in one of these oppressed groups
anywhere they would need to invent it
because
there's an ample supply of it already on
offer
there's a whole you know there's a
there's a a buffet of oppression that's
that's that's there at all times they
don't need to they don't need to um
invent additional oppression you think
about you know an example would be
christian minorities in the middle east
who are
oppressed and persecuted and killed
they're they're not in making it up
they're not inventing additional
instances of it if they get
executed if they're at church and get
rounded up and executed by muslim
militants
that that's all the oppression that is
needed
they're not going to go and come up with
some other example it wouldn't make any
sense to do
that and thirdly and this is important
truly oppressed groups have no appetite
for fake martyrdom
oppression and victimization isn't a
game to them it's real
the last thing they would want is to
exaggerate or fabricate
there's no appetite for that no no
desire for it
it's kind of like if you know if someone
who isn't actually sick
but exaggerates their symptoms to get
sympathy or maybe to get out of work or
you know as i used to do
very often as a kid to get out of school
compare that
to someone who's very sick legitimately
sick
let's say so sick they're in the
hospital maybe even deathly sick maybe
they're
you know they've got terminal cancer
something a very sick person
now that person isn't going to
exaggerate symptoms
they're not going to make up symptoms
they don't have because there's no need
anyway
the symptoms are bad enough as it is and
also
they'd be in no mood for that for them
sickness is not a game it isn't play
acting it isn't a tool they're using
it's just it's real it's terrible it's
inescapable
and they just want to get better they
want to be free of the sickness that's
their desire
oppressed people seek to be free of the
oppression
they don't seek to extend it or add to
it
or or uh you know
fabricate it or find more of it or
create it
they want to be free bubba wallace
is not oppressed he is not a victim
he is a rich man of power and privilege
he lives a luxurious and
enviable life he lives a better life
than almost everyone else on earth okay
he is at the he's
he is in terms of everyone on earth and
everyone that's ever existed on earth
being a you know being a famous person a
a rich uh
professional athlete he's up close to
the top
[Music]
and all of that i think made him greedy
uh he wanted more and he used fake
victimization to get
more because no real victimization was
on offer for him
this com this country is not
systemically racist against him
which is good news and something that he
would celebrate
and should celebrate if he weren't a
fraud
which he is
and that's the other thing the very
revealing thing
when i when something is claimed to be a
hate crime and it turns out not to be
one
notice how the left and the race
hustlers
and um and you know hacks like uh like
al sharpton notice they're upset they're
angry
palpable disappointment is on their face
and in their words they're desperate to
preserve it as some kind of hate crime
or
sort of a hate crime semi-hate crime
what does that tell you they should be
relieved they should be saying thank god
and then they should also be embarrassed
that they were fooled relief and
embarrassment should be the two things
um but no no they
they're they're clinging on to it they
want it
the people on the left they wanted they
they wish it was a hate crime
they are disappointed that it isn't and
i think that right there tells you
everything you need to know and we'll
leave it there today thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clavin